Hello and welcome to this video on the theory for Python in Unreal Engine integration.
So one of the first important things to understand is how Python integrates within the engine.
So you might be aware that Unreal Engine is written in a programming language called C++.
Now this is a very powerful programming language which is a little bit difficult to use
and requires an external editor and compiling of the code in order to actually go and use.
Now there are a couple other options which allow you to code within the editor itself. So
the editor being the program that you're probably most used to with Unreal Engine which allows you
to create and package a game. Now the first one is blueprints and if you're doing this video,
I'm hoping by this point you are aware of blueprints. Well what they are is exposed
C++ code which you can use in a user-friendly graphical scripting language.
This is very powerful and can be used to create entire games. Now in addition to this we have
something called Python and Python is one of the most commonly used programming languages
around the world. It has a more readable markup language and it's very common to find
people who work in it. Now this is brilliant for creating tools. Now Python itself does not
compile to runtime so this is purely used within the editor for sort of tool making.
But again what this Python does is it just calls compiled C++. So much like how blueprints work
where we have compiled C++ that we can just be referencing, Python works in a very similar way.
So C++ blueprints and Python. Now if you were to open up C++ and some of the engines compiled
you're going to find that you've got a whole load of different functions and passes and stuff
and some of these will be marked as blueprint callable. And this is what allows you to
it to be exposed and accessible via the blueprint system. Now the same codes which are last blueprint
callable a lot of them are also automatically exposed and accessible via Python.
So as soon as you can see here we have an example of the spawn actor from object we
can see it in C++, the blueprints and the Python code we're looking at.
So we are generally working with the same code. Each of these languages have specific strengths
and we're going to go over and we're going to look at Python. So why might you decide to use
Python? First case you prefer coding in Python. There are a lot of people who are much more
used to using Python than either of the other different methods. The other very powerful one
is it communicates well with other softwares. So many other softwares are accessible via Python
and if you're looking at making something that's sort of pipeline orientated it's good to be able
to talk to each of the systems from the same place. You can also access pre-written libraries
of code. So there are numerous libraries of code which are already out there for Python
and by using this method you're going to be able to use that functionality within Unreal.
It's also good for running large tasks without Unreal quitting. So Unreal if you create
something and run it via blueprints if it is a very long task blueprints may consider it to be
hitting an infinite loop and it will quit out. Now this isn't true with Python which is quite useful
if you have an incredibly large amount of data to sort through. Last thing you want it to do is
go away for a long while and then just quit before finishing. It also is one of the best
ways I think of manipulating the editor setup itself. So if you want to change and edit how
the editor is set up Python is a really really strong way to do this. One of the other things
that we've used internally quite a lot is it's great for compatibility between
UE versions. If you want to go and talk between two different versions of the editor or
update stuff we often use custom Python scripts to do this. And the final method as well is
there are a greater number of people who can support Python code rather than C++.
It is just a more accessible language there are more people out there who can do it. So by
writing in Python you have a bigger pool of expertise to call on. So how is Python integrated
with the engine? Well we have a version of Python which comes installed with the version of
the engine. And that Python version at present is 3.11.8. And the reason this has been selected
is because it fits in very well with the standardized VFX pipelines that are out there.
Now this may be updated but we will update it along with the VFX pipelines. Python is often
used within virtual production quite a lot because you don't have to have stuff encoded at runtime.
Within virtual production everything usually runs within the editor meaning Python is a lot
more accessible. It can be used in a lot more cases. So that's why we have defaulted to that
pipeline. However you are not stuck to use 3.11.8. The only reason that the system is using
that is because we have set up by default a tick box on in the plugin for Python that is
Isolate Interpreter Environment. And this will be ticked on by default and while this is ticked
on you are not going to use the environment which is set up on your own personal machine.
Now this is also great because it means that code that is written is going to be
compilable and runnable on most different integrations and people who are running. So if
you hand somebody an Unreal project the likelihood is the Python code is going to run because
we're standardizing to this Python library. If you untick this box and set your UE underscore
Python underscore directory environmental variable it's you can choose the Python library that you
want to use. So that's the standard Python library that you have however we have a specific
Unreal Python library and this is where we will find the exposed Unreal C++
calls. Now there are a few things that it's worth noting with this. The first thing is
and I'll demonstrate it in a minute but you should be able to find an Unreal Python API
online and just search for Unreal Python API or you can go to to the URL here
and find the different versions but feel free to go and have a look at that yourself we will
touch on it when we go into the exercises however there's a couple of things that are
important to understand. First one is there is no on disk version of this Unreal module
so this means it is entirely created in memory. This is important because it's going to mean a
couple of different things. Firstly you cannot access it if you don't have a version of Unreal
running. The most times you'll do this you will run it through through Unreal to get hold
of the library it's because it just won't exist. Secondly it means by default it isn't
going to integrate with an integrated development environment an IDE. So where you might have
an integrated development environment it's not going to directly be able to pull for it
from this. We do have a solution though if you want to do something like set up auto-complete
in your own IDE we have a method of generating something that's called a stub file and this
can be added to your IDE in order to use that kind of functionality such as also complete.
If you want to do this there is an article on our website called setting up auto-complete
for editor python scripting. It's going to walk you through the process of setting that up.
Next up using external libraries the chances are you're going to want to use a different
external libraries with Unreal in order to add to its functionality. Now this because we have
the isolated environment we are not necessarily going to have access to all the libraries which
you have on your setup. Now in case that's the situation what we need is a path so that
that library can be found. Now there are a number of different ways of doing that in this for
example I'm showing how I would package up the python libraries into the python code directory
on my project and then I'll be able to import them as long as I have the system library path
added in. Now there are some default paths which will come with the system so you can have
the content slash python and the subfolders are going to be part of the path content python sub
folders in the main unreal engine installation will also be but bear in mind if you're sharing
the project different people might have different installations content path also for subfolders
in enabled plugins meaning you can package up libraries with a part a plugin in order to
um hand it to somebody and documents unreal engine python folder.
Now you can actually go into the plugins and add extra paths in or you can add them
programmatically like we showed in the previous slide. Now to start with that's all the theory
that you're going to need before we jump into the project. There are project files which
come with this and I suggest you fire them up and follow along the expectation is that you
carry out the exercises with us it's also useful as a sort of dumping ground for a whole
load of different code that you can you can play around with so I'll see you in the next
video when we will be jumping into the project.